The area practices document has this
to say about the radio group pattern.
Use a container with a roll radio
group for the set of radio buttons.
So we set that attribute here.
Then individual radio
buttons have a role of radio.
So we set that here for
each radio button.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now if a radio button's selected, it's
aria-checked attribute needs to be true
and if it's not selected
it needs to be false.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We come here to this
changeFocus function.
We need to make sure that we
keep the aria-checked attribute
in sync with the checked value.
So we need to modify our JavaScript.
So that every time we change
the checked attribute,
we also change
the aria-checked attribute.
[BLANK_AUDIO]